على اراضيها وعندها قوانينها منهم قانون
يقال
اقامه منذ 68
وهذا بلد يحرص على تطبيق قوانين
هدايا لازم نحط الامور في اطارها ونبتعد
على كل ما هو
امور اخرى تتجاوز الحقيقه هذا الاطار ثم
تعرفوا ابعاد
ما حقاش خذيتها
ولكن مع الاسف بفعل ولكن اليوم المهم ان
هناك
وزاره الخارجيه
والوزارات التونسيه والهيئه الاخرى في هذا
احنا
اخبرنا معناتها
مع مجموعه السفارات البلدان الفارقه
الموجودين في تونس في نفس هذه القاعه
وكانت الحقيقه
مقابل جيده وكان فما فيها
تفاهم تام
كان فيها تفاهم تام
وتحدثنا ببرشا عقلانيه وكانوا متفاهمين
الازمه هديه فيها جانب كبير مفتعل
الموضوع الاساسي اللي هو نحبوا سلامه كل
ما يعيش على التراب التونسي واحترام قانون
البلاد مره اخرى
المرانا الا بعد الاجتماع هذايا مع السفر
على فارقه
كيما نقول تم معناتها كان ايجابي جدا
وخذينا صوره جماعيه وتحدثنا على مكان تونس
في افريقيا
وفيقيه تونس
وعمق هذه العلاقات الى اخره وعملنا حتى
الصوره جماعيه وشدين يدين بعضنا على اساس
ما نتعلم
بين كل الدول الافريقيه وبشمه ما تندس حتى
فكره اللي تجي تضرب هيك التضامن هذاك
ونتوما تعرفوا الهجره الموضوع يفوت بلد
واحد تونس بالذات هو مرتبط معناتها بشبكات
عالميه وهو موضوع يهمه عديد الدول في
العالم اكثر من غيرها والحل ديما كما تقول
تونس الحل يكون كان بالتعاون وبالتشاور مع
جميع الاطراف المعنيه
فما رانا كان من بعد الاتحاد الافريقي
خارج بيان هذاك كان كان كاسح وكان مرفوض
رجع تعليل وزاره الخارجيه في ساعتين من
بعد
رجعت عليه ورفضناه وذكرناه ما فيش داعي
الموجهه لتونس اللي هي معروفه في العالم
كبلد مضياف وبلد يستقبلوا بلد عاشت فيها
عديد الحضارات انه اليوم تونس
بالعنصريه هذا الشيء
ما يستقيمش وربما مضحك
اتصلنا
بالاعلام الدولي وعملت تصريحات في فرنسا
24 وعلى اساس باللغه الفرنسيه
العديد من البلدان الافريقيه تدخل اللغه
الفرنساويه
وبالانجليزيه زاده التصريحات
مضاده تخدم وقلت من الاهميه بتاعها وبداوا
يعطيوه في الاخبار من الاتحاد الافريقي
وغيره
على حساب التوضيحات اللي قامت فهذه ان شاء
الله اليوم فرصه باش نزيد نتوجهوا للراي
العام في تونس والراي العام الدولي فشل
نحط الامور في ايطاليا